you name a movie that is absolutely
incredible not Star Wars that you've
seen over a dozen times
well let's
a movie that I've seen over a dozen
times that is
a movie that also I come back to to kind
of renew my faith in movies is Blade
Runner I think by Ridley Scott The World
building in Blade Runner the sci-fi film
noir
um you know Harrison Ford's performance
very unlike
how we knew Harrison Ford when he played
Han Solo
and I think that that film has been
incredibly influential not just with
other movies other dystopian films
because dystopian films of that era
didn't necessarily take themselves too
seriously you know they were
um borderline like sci-fi Adventure
comedies but um
you know Blade Runner is a classic
and it it has you know it's it's
influential till today not just in
movies but also in video games and in
design and it's funny you know
it's it's really funny looking at how
Forward Thinking Blade Runner is in the
sense that okay we don't have flying
cars
but we we do have many of the things
that are in Blade Runner LA's become
very Multicultural much more than uh the
time in which it was made
so that's a movie I can just put on
anytime
and watch
yeah and I think Philip K dick talked
about
um that he envisioned a world where the
higher Social strata would live up top
and and as people's income and sort of
like place in society yeah they would be
more toward the bottom I mean Blade
Runner in a way kind of predicted the uh
economic divide that we're currently
experiencing
with more and more people being pushed
from the middle class
to lower middle class or worse and a
huge divide between the elites and
everybody else
and it's unfortunate but that that movie
that's that's an element of Blade Runner
can you tell us about the movies that we
want to watch over and over again versus
the movies we just want to see one time
maybe they were satisfying enough but
we're good one and done
I think that the movies that we watch
over and over again uh were seeking one
comfort food it's a film I'm familiar
with
2001 A Space Odyssey is a movie that
I'll watch several times a year and if
it's at a retrospective screening
I'll be sitting in a perfect spot in the
theater for that movie but I think we're
seeking some kind of meaning and I will
say with the films that I do repeatedly
view they're ones that I saw probably an
impressionable age
but also I'm looking at it differently
so it's interesting to see a film I saw
when I was say 11 years old like Logan's
Run
okay and then I see it differently now
as an adult
uh and and so that's what's that's what
I find fascinating about films that we
watch on repeat or will have repeated
viewings at different phases of life
because it's in some way kind of a
reflection of us
and and so those films for me are you
know movies like a Logan's Run or a 2001
A Space Odyssey or Tron and it's funny
that those movies perhaps with the
exception of Logan's Runner still
remembered
um I think Logan's Run is more revered
for the performances of Michael York and
Jenny agater than than the actual
special effects
your mileage may vary on the special
effects for that film but 2001
holds up to today and I don't think that
we would have had a Star Wars or George
Lucas if Stanley Kubrick had not made
2001 because 2001 A Space Odyssey the
special effects from that film actually
directly influenced George Lucas he
thought well now I can make a science
fiction film with spaceships and laser
guns but I want it to be taken seriously
I don't want it to be a joke but those
those films we we revisit we're trying
to revisit I think I think it's a
reflection of us now and also revisiting
perhaps who you were when that movie
made an impression
so I think of myself as a kid being
dropped off at the movie theater in
Michigan by my mom to go see Logan's Run
which was PG and probably shouldn't been
there's an ample amount of nudity and
and deeper themes in that film
um but but that that is a film that
resonates for me today that you could
hardly convince anyone now to watch it
because it definitely feels the special
effects are dated for sure but I don't
know that you'll find a better romance
in a science fiction film than Logan's
Run
so I kind of
I kind of revisit that film it was you
know
um seeing that you know by myself seeing
it in a theater a couple times after
that
um when it came to the dollar theater
and then also kind of was my first
interest in in you know I I was a young
boy I liked girls and so that movie was
a romance and uh
so yeah it reminds me of just being a
kid and that was sort of my first
interest in girls was was seeing Logan's
Run oddly
what's interesting when you when we
re-watch a movie let's say like Kramer
versus Kramer which I probably saw way
too young but I thought it was so funny
but now as an adult you watch it and
it's it's very sad it's it's yeah Kramer
versus Kramer is heartbreaking it's not
um I mean there are a lot of uh you know
moments of levity for sure right a lot
but but there are there's so much more
going on I do think that that era in the
70s and even like partially into the 80s
was such a great
era of American filmmaking you know I I
tell people revisit those films that was
when there was less far less Studio
influence
studios in fact didn't really know what
to do you know the marketing in
particular uh wasn't as sophisticated as
it is now or as controlled and I mean
that in a good way
I go back and watch the original
trailers for any movie from the 70s they
didn't know how to make a movie trailer
back then or at least they didn't have
the sort of very traditional kind of
trailery things that we see the the
voice over the certain certain types of
musical notes and themes that are
overused quite a bit and you know
um you you could look up videos on this
there are so many so many ways that they
test these trailers because they're
tracking emotion there's certain
emotions and beats that they want to hit
in addition to basically ruining most of
the movie up until potentially the third
act and if you're familiar with the
genre you can probably figure out what's
going to happen it's rare I see a
trailer these days for a studio movie
that doesn't completely ruin the entire
film
is that theater still there in Michigan
I don't believe it is unfortunately it
was the Berkeley Theater was turned into
a drugstore
but the Berkeley Theater was walking
distance or at least bicycle distance
from my house and I would go see movies
every week at that theater it was
because it was only a dollar and there
was a drugstore directly next door where
I bought comic books
can you name a movie that was absolutely
incredible to watch but you've only seen
it one time
uh yes
and I'm sad to tell you it was the human
centipede
uh there there was if you know anything
about the story of The Human Centipede
it's absolutely horrific and I'm not
going to describe it for you
do your research at your peril but
that's a film I saw once because I had
to see it
um and I I did review it for a a job at
the time I was doing movie reviews on on
G4 TV
and I had to see the film watched it was
horrified it stuck in my mind have no
interest in revisiting it and it left
quite an impression but normally movies
I only see once I only see them once for
a reason and that's because they're not
very good
and I don't wish to revisit them Human
Centipede I thought just the concept of
it it's it's horrifying and I guess what
what did stand out to me is that it's
not as as graphic from a horror
standpoint as you might think
it's it's much more psychological that's
the type of horror film that I prefer is
a psychological horror film because I
feel like
you know that is a movie that will stay
with you
that is a movie that when you
turn off the lights at night
to to to go to sleep is gonna still be
in your head
and maybe you want to turn the light
back on and read a book
to kind of change the change the sort of
hamster wheel uh spinning around in your
head about about a move and that's where
I knew a movie is is really good is when
I can't stop thinking about it
most unfortunately a lot of films that I
see I'll see one time and and they're
fairly forgettable you know they're
they're sort of that middle ground it's
the ones that are really bad or really
exceptional are the ones that stand out
in my memory there's another class of
movies I I think that like almost
require a second viewing in order to
fully experience them
I'll give you a couple of examples the
movie memento
Christopher Nolan's second feature film
starring Guy Pierce is a movie that upon
second viewing
you'll you'll notice all the details
that you missed
and and so that one really really left
an impression on me another film I would
say Darren aronofsky's the fountain it's
not one that's brought up too often
um
but that film really really left an
impression upon me I think Darren
Aronofsky is a brilliant filmmaker and
the fountain is another one that I
believe you can appreciate more upon
second viewing because you have things
happening in different time periods kind
of that that are
reflecting or echoing each other so to
speak so I do think that in addition to
movies you may only see once I think
that movies that that require a second
viewing to to gain more from it I think
are are really important to explore
what do you love about Disney Live
Action remakes
uh I don't love anything about Disney
Live Action remakes I think these are
the worst films of our time
that represent everything wrong with
Factory filmmaking and
Studio Executives and lawyers deciding
they need to make a movie to somehow
preserve the intellectual property
and the Disney Live Action remakes with
the exception of a few I would say the
Jungle Book by John Favreau but almost
all of them have been
incredibly unwatchable
uh thankfully the classic films on which
they're based still exist you know uh
films like Pinocchio Beauty and the
Beast and whatnot but the live action
remakes have been the worst Pinocchio in
particular was one that had me
specifically angry
because
it was in first of all embarrassing at
how bad the film was
it's everything wrong you're taking the
design of the original Pinocchio and
rendering it in computer animation and
it's the exact same design you get Tom
Hanks to play Geppetto who
it's interesting you know in the
original animation of Pinocchio it's you
you have Geppetto and he's so excited to
have a young boy a son but when you take
these Concepts and from animation 2D
animation and put them into live action
there's something about it that is at
the very least unsettling of a
live-action Tom Hanks dancing with joy
that he has a young boy
a young live boy
that's his
I don't want to like
I don't know how long of a dramatic
pause I could put there after saying
those words but there's something about
it that just seems weird in live action
and I think that that's something if you
look at um animated shows like The
Simpsons when they talk about religion
or politics uh or just so many different
issues that The Simpsons touch on you
could never do that in live action you
couldn't do a live-action sitcom that
discussed those ideas
I mean you used to be able to with all
in the family but the only way to tackle
those ideas unfortunately in a
mainstream way is uh is in 2D animation
or at least you used to be able to
but the but the live-action Disney films
are
just a travesty and sort of represent
everything wrong with modern movies
today
everything wrong uh just the you know
updating it for modern audiences uh with
um unnecessary gender and race swaps uh
that I think that audiences are
beginning to Tire of
um the live action doesn't really work
there's certain Concepts and ideas that
work best in animation perhaps that's
why perhaps that's why the Jungle Book
is probably the one that stands out as
it is the most watchable and probably
um the best of them
is because it's it's all animated it's
all animated with the exception of the
young boy but
but my God these these Disney animated
or these Disney Animation translations
to live action are are travesty I feel
like I could teach a class where we just
watch parts of Pinocchio daily and I
tell you why this isn't working
um
you know there's even a scene in which
Pinocchio trips over a pile of feces
covered in flies
and
part of me thinks that the reason that
the feces in Pinocchio with the the
Flies you could hear the Flies is so
graphic it was like the animators put
that in to let us know yeah we know
we know too they are this bad
and that film just
um it just
it's it's horrific I I really get the
sense that it's it's
um an attorney is saying look we need to
remake these and we need to brand them
to remind people
it's it's somewhat similar to there was
a trend in the 90s to do sequels to
classic Disney animated films Cinderella
to
Lion King 2
Bambi to
um and you can probably find them at
yard sales
um in the clamshell VHS casing you can
find the sequels to all the classic
Disney animated features and they're all
completely forgettable and I wish they
never existed
and I would say the same for all of
these Disney Live Action films is
literally an attorney saying well
just do it I I am I it's disappointing
to see people like uh Robert zemeckis
who made you know
a short on a short list of perfect films
Made Back to the Future
right and then to see Tom Hanks
probably the most beloved actor
um
you know you could still call him a star
for them to team up with Disney to make
it is horrific
and I just hope that Disney stops
not to get too graphic but I am curious
with the pile of feces and the Flies uh
what in what context was that in the
scene well Pinocchio is skipping his way
to school he's distracted and happens
upon a pile of feces it's a completely
unnecessary
thing to happen in the midst of the
live-action remake of the classic
Pinocchio to put in this pile of feces
but I do believe that that was a not so
secret message
that the animators may have just decided
to add
um
why would they do this
uh otherwise there's there's no point in
it does it pay off later in the story
is it on his shoe and he says um I I I
don't I don't recall that it that it
pays off or has meaning but the pile of
feces in the live-action Pinocchio is
the most likable character
oh okay great I say I say that with a
straight face
I have some numbers here uh Lion King
1.6 billion dollars worldwide Beauty and
the Beast 1.2 billion
Aladdin over a billion World worldwide
and The Jungle Book almost a billion
so what about the fact that many of
these remakes are huge business you talk
about a lawyer that could be sitting
behind their you know thing their
computer figuring out numbers yeah
doesn't it make sense though
sure it makes Financial sense to remake
classic and familiar intellectual
property in to another form from live
action to or from animation to live
action that makes total sense on paper
uh I think these films are completely
creatively bankrupt and forgettable and
it's unfortunate that audiences
um would not be more discriminating when
it comes to these comes to these movies
so I I just don't think that we're going
to be talking about any of these
live-action Disney remakes far into the
future will still be discussing the
classic films upon upon which they're
based and now forgive me I'm not a
parent but I know that you know moms
need a break dads need a break is this
the kind of movie that hey guys we're
gonna get in the car and go see a movie
what are we going to see Pinocchio there
there is there is definitely a school of
thought that will that will say that the
reason that these movies are profitable
is they're effectively uh babysitters so
um that could could also be a reason for
the success and also I kind of find it
there's always a movie and this is in
particular around the holidays usually
Thanksgiving or or Christmas and whatnot
there's a movie that
um offends no one is not interesting
completely forgettable but it's the only
movie the entire family can agree that
we can all go see together
so that's why you see movies opening on
Christmas day right that it is a thing a
lot of movies open on Christmas Day
and not everybody wants to go see The
Godfather 3 on Christmas Day
but they'll go see something like
like
a Disney live action
remake I I despise these films with
every fiber of my being so I find they
uh
you know I mean I guess the best thing
you can say about them is it keeps
certain artists employed
we have another quote here we've done
this with you in the past and uh
wondering if you can read this quote
here and uh not sure if you know who it
is but uh let's see if I can figure it
out okay I feel like I'm on a game show
now
um I am a filmmaker my job is to make
films when something excites you a story
or characterization you immediately
forget about everything else you only
think how to make a movie out of it the
economics come only later you shouldn't
let money dictate the kind of films you
should make
well I I really love that statement I'm
not exactly sure who wrote it but
I love that I think well there's a
couple things it's it's an it's
unfortunate that um filmmaking is the
most expensive art form
even if you make a film on your iPhone
at some point you're going to have to do
a professional sound mix you're going to
have to use color correction you're
going to have to spend some money to
market the film
right so even movies at a low budget
level money is sort of the unspoken
producer of every movie
that's why when you see the movies with
the highest budgets you know many times
they appeal to everyone and no one
and don't exactly leave leave you with
any sort of lasting impression
but I think money is always the unspoken
producer and in addition money is for
many beginning filmmakers an excuse to
not make a movie
so
I feel like you need to kind of set all
those excuses aside find out what your
Baseline level budget is to tell a story
and if there's a way to do it
leap right in but now you have to tell
me who said this I I don't know speaking
of leap thinking of the dancing scene
that would be SS Raj muli sorry oh wow
SS Roger muli said that wow that's
fantastic he um
I'm I become a quick fan of ss rajamouli
he directed a film called RR which is a
tollywood film
it's it's really interesting in India
they really have competing film
Industries they have Bollywood which
many people are familiar with Bollywood
and Associate most of Indian Cinema with
Bollywood but there's also tollywood
uh and and there I think that the
rivalry between the two industries is
actually made for better films
and I will say
I discovered RR when it was number three
at the box office the weekend that the
Batman opened
and I found that really strange how is
it that the weekend that this biggest
superhero movie you know Robert
Pattinson is the Batman that this movie
rrr
suddenly is Unleashed in the United
States
and
I went to see it on a whim based on a
recommendation from a friend and
noticing like how did this film and the
film just blew my mind three-hour epic
very Loosely based on two historical
figures
and it has everything Hollywood movies
wish they had today
just compelling instantly likable
characters it very much felt like an old
style Hollywood movie a mix of you know
yes there are dance numbers there's also
romance and humor action there's heroism
acts of self-sacrifice I don't know that
Hollywood can make a film like rrr and
it's it's really disappointing to me
oddly enough rrr is the I believe the
highest budget movie
ever to come from India at 75 million
dollars
and it's it's really quite an
achievement when you see the film I
would have thought it would be it would
have been in the hundreds of millions of
dollars to make this movie
but the fact that it's 75 million
dollars and so epic in scale there's a
scene in at the near the beginning of
the film in the First Act
character named ROM who is an officer at
an outpost
it's being protested
and it's an action sequence where ROM is
sort of set on a mission to to grab a
perpetrator who threw a rock
he he goes to try to track down this
perpetrator it's an epic action scene
you can't believe I mean it's just
something on a scale we've never seen I
was shocked to learn that they took
almost 30 days to shoot that scene with
20 000 extras not digital effects
20 000 extras
so
the achievement of this film is so
remarkable
and it makes me sad that like hey you
know Hollywood can't compete with this
and I I do see when you go to your local
Cinema
wherever your local movie theater is
you're seeing more and more you know not
necessarily your Hollywood movie but
anime
you're seeing
um Spanish language films Indian films I
mean
um at the AMC theaters that I go to in
Southern California there is at least a
new Indian movie every month sometimes
two a month
I personally love that because I've
always enjoyed you know uh World Cinema
has I I've always enjoyed it but this
film is something special
one interesting thing that I would point
out about RR
is
Americans reaction to this movie
everyone I know that has seen it has
really loved it but what I find
interesting is we live at a time where
politics is infused into nearly every
art form comic books writing movies
television
it's uh I I could use a break frankly
from being lectured to no one likes to
be lectured to and this film does not do
that but there are thematically some
interesting things that are opposing in
it and I'm really surprised that that
I've never seen anyone point this out
about RR on the one hand
the villains of the film are the
colonizers you know the British
the Sun never sets on the British Empire
is what they say and there's a character
governor Scott in in rrr that is I mean
he is a villain right out of a Star Wars
movie with the British accent and
whatnot so the white Colonial Invaders
of India are the bad people
now that is a political messaging
it's also a real historical thing that
happened okay so it's not like it's a
message but
that's something that would appeal to
one side of the political aisle would be
hey the colonizers are the baddies in
this movie
in addition in the same movie
there is also a thread about guns
and
owning a gun and the correct use of a
gun responsible use of a weapon
will lead to Freedom
the character ROM who I mentioned
earlier you get a flashback in the
second half of the film with young Rahm
and his father
and he's teaching him about the value of
a bullet the value of a bullet being you
know worth more than the life of an
Indian
uh and and and how that kind of plays
through he tells them the value of
bullet what it can do responsible gun
use you see sort of training an army to
to basically you know
fight their way to freedom from the
British colonizers
so on the one hand you have a movie
that's very anti-colonizer
that is also very pro-second Amendment
you could look at it that way I don't
think I've seen a movie
I can't even think of a film that
contains
if you've seen the movie RR as many
times as I have you'll notice it
two opposing
sides of the political aisle in terms of
messaging one being anti-colonizer
another one being pro-gun
I don't know that SS Raja Mali intended
it to be that way I don't believe he's
lecturing in any portion of the film at
all I think it's all organic to the
story I just find it fascinating that
not one person has pointed this out
that's interesting I hadn't even thought
of it I'm referring back to the scene
that you're talking about and there's
also just to keep it lighter there's
friendship there's romance there's
amazing dance sequences and then there's
these animals right animals all
digitally the animals are all digitally
created right but also ROM's Mission
which his sort of his family is
decimated and murdered by the the
colonizers right by the British
um the British soldiers wipe out his
family and his tribe nearly everyone in
his tribe and then he grows up and he's
on a mission to get the guns because
guns will lead to freedom and if I mean
India was not United as a country at the
time this
for a historical frame of reference the
story the story of our art takes place
in the 1920s
uh it's also based on two real
historical figures and imagines if they
had met right
um they never actually didn't eat but
but the film kind of is is definitely I
would call it historical fantasy
but you you know India was not United as
a country it was
um groups of tribes
and and the British colonizers coming in
kind of helped unite the people
and and the the rahm's mission is his
whole mission is to get weapons and then
deliver them to his tribes so they can
fight for their freedom and at least
fight on an even playing field with the
British having guns and them having guns
so
um you know these are sensitive things
to think about and talk about because
we live at a time where you know even if
you reveal even a hint at what your
politics might be it could be a death
sentence for a career which is sad to me
it's sad that we can't have open and
honest conversations about
a whole number of issues I would love to
be able to do that
but it's funny that this wildly
successful
um very mainstream and entertaining
almost a tip of the hat to old Hollywood
film RR has woven into it
some messages you could read read in
that are that are uh that are right in
the middle of the Divide of where people
are right now in the United States and
are they on two different religious
spectrums as well in the film no they
don't not so much
I mean the film does deal with that but
what I love about SS Raja Mali as a
filmmaker he was asked in an interview
or the interviewer asked him said hey
have you thought about doing a Marvel
movie you should you you know based on
the action in rrr you should be making a
Marvel movie
and SS Raja Mali said I have no interest
in doing a Marvel movie I don't want to
do that and he wants to keep his focus
on telling stories from Indian history
and Indian mysticism and and fables and
I think that that is why I so admire uh
Raja Mali is a filmmaker because he
wants to stick to his roots
you know and I I think that that's
incredibly admirable
did you expect to love the movie going
in
I didn't know I didn't know what to
expect about rrr when I went in to see
it I I just thought well okay it's three
hours I I know I'm gonna have to take a
break
at some point there's going to be an
intermission whether there is one or not
but I just fell in love with it because
because it reminded me of a type of
movie that Hollywood used to make which
wasn't any genre you could easily just
say well RR is an action movie it's not
just that it's also a historical fantasy
it's also a love story in fact there are
two love stories
maybe three if you encount if you count
the friendship between beam and ROM
so
it really is you know in my top
probably top five if not top three
movies of the year
and it should give Hollywood pause
to see how successful this film is
internationally how it's beloved by
anyone that sees it if there's a way to
see rrr in a movie theater I strongly
recommend it
um
I you know I've seen it in the theater
four times I'm actually going to see it
for a fifth time in the theater and when
you see this movie it's like a
celebration I haven't seen an audience
react this way to a film in a theater
since the very end of you know Avengers
end game that sort of swell of
you don't want to just clap you want to
stand up and applaud you want to scream
for joy
I mean I can think of times in the past
where I've you know screamed at a movie
theater and and applauded uh for Joy but
I haven't done that
I haven't done that with a Hollywood
film probably since that scene and end
game the portals scene which is the the
very end of the film I thought that was
like that was the combination of 10
years of Marvel movies and and telling
effectively what turned out to be one
story leading to that epic battle
Nothing Compares except for the film RR
and and seeing it in the theater is for
me um if it's playing I'm gonna go uh
I'm just so taken with this film and I
think there's so much there's so much to
learn from it and I really hope that
Hollywood learns the lesson of you know
please stop the lecturing
tell audiences a story that they can be
engaged with
uh with characters that you fall in love
with
and I think I think really that formula
is fairly simple I don't I don't know
where we got to this place where we felt
it necessary to infuse all of our
entertainment with
uh with with some sort of lecturing it's
just you just don't need it
it's tollywood you said tollywood yes
um there yeah I you know I am still
learning about all this my understanding
is they're two dominant languages in
India there's Telugu and Hindi and
sometimes you will see
um you know they'll come out in
different languages I'm not obviously
I'm seeing it with the subtitles I can't
speak either language
um the only words I know are not do not
do which is the dance number the dance
number in in the middle of our RR
we're ROM and beam do the not to not to
dance right then it turns into a
dance-off
some people some friends of mine have
recommended rr2 they they kind of cringe
for a minute like oh is it's one of
those Bollywood movies with dance
numbers and I correct them because I was
corrected it's tollywood and and the
dance number is a big part of the story
it's a huge part of the story so it's
not just put in there just to be in
there right there's a purpose there's a
purpose for natu natu to be in the
middle of that and God I wish I had the
skills that those actors did in that
scene it's it's it's really really
remarkable
so
God just
if I could say one thing just go see RR
in the theater if you have the
opportunity
can thank me later
what do you think about Amazon shutting
down reviews
for rings of power
wow Amazon shutting down reviews of
rings of power is very disingenuous
I I am a fan of reviews on Amazon
I can't tell you how many times it's
helped me pick out the correct product
um and I'm talking not about movies here
I'm talking about just product reviews
it's very bizarre to me also that even
that
you know being a Critic is such a weird
thing like we you know we find Critic
reviews of things useful reviews of cars
reviews of restaurants these are all
useful things right but when it comes to
to
you know movies television shows that's
where people's passions come out I think
that Amazon shutting down the reviews
for rings of power is well it's it's in
their best interests but also exposes
that
um they're not allowing
potential fans of the show to speak
their minds
I I think I think it's a it's going to
be a mistake in the long run
and I I also think having seen
the shows or at least half of the first
season
at the time of this taping um
it it's
really the whole thing was just
ill-conceived from the beginning
and the fact that they really couldn't
endear true Tolkien fans in what they
were attempting to achieve is is really
uh disheartening but the shutting down
of those reviews is I mean they're going
to show if they're not going to show up
on Amazon they're going to show up
somewhere else they're going to show up
in a YouTube video they're going to show
up in a comment section on a YouTube
video or something else they're gonna
people are going to be able to speak
their minds about how they feel about
the show if it's not on the Amazon
website it's going to be somewhere else
so there's really no way to to
completely shut it down and I think I
think it shows that you know they're
fearing the the reviews of
just regular people that want to talk
about their love or hate for the show
what is pandering to film journalists
well look I could teach a class on
pandering to film journalists I don't
know why that this became a thing it it
kind of evolved but you do see in a lot
of you you see this occur a lot when it
comes to marketing when it comes to
marketing a film or a television show
they'll highlight certain aspects of the
show that may not be a big aspect of the
movie itself but they'll throw in a
quick line you know
um they call it uh sometimes they'll be
an inconsequential character who happens
to be gay they call it queerbaiting
right so you'll get like a character who
happens to be gay who is in a TV show or
a movie and then it's loudly announced
that this character is gay and look we
have gay representation
but the character really is not
meaningful to the overall story so
I I really hate it when I see that that
Studios Pander to journalists and what
they seem to be looking for in the way
in the interest of getting like good
press for a TV show or a movie
and then I feel like it backfires
because it completely misrepresents the
movie and TV show and then I do believe
that it can turn off the audience
how do actors bully fans
oh
I I find it really sad to see actors
bullying fans these days
um I I first of all I think it's
completely unnecessary
and I think that if they've got time to
scroll through social media
and Bully fans over opinions I think
that's
uh I don't know I don't think that's the
best use of your time I think one of the
best things you can do for your mental
health is just to not be on social media
unfortunately for me I'm on social media
for for work for the most part I I don't
really
you know I I don't use I don't use
social media as a way to fight with
strangers
and I I
look if I was running a studio and I
hired Talent the first thing I would do
is have them pass over give me their
passwords to all their social media
accounts they would no longer have
access to them and I think kind of the
less I know about the personal life of a
celebrity
the more I tend to like them
so whenever I see like an unhinged actor
or celebrity go after
just someone on social media who might
have rubbed them the wrong way I just
think that it's they're they're they're
usually having a bad day or dealing with
something the problem I do think with
with actors is
they go through stretches where they
work very hard
and then the other eight months of the
year they have nothing to do
and that time
you know that idle time can be spent
unwisely
so yeah I I'm not a fan whenever I
witness that I think it's I think it's
completely unnecessary and it's just
made me think less of the the person in
question I I'll say also I do try to
when I see a movie that may have
included someone who's involved in some
recent internet nonsense
I try to separate myself from that so
that I can actually enjoy the work for
what it is
um
you know in particular recently there
was a case with uh uh I was kind of
reluctant to see clerks three
you know I I just I've always enjoyed
Kevin Smith as a filmmaker in his early
days I think he was something of a hero
to a lot of people
you know
with clerks one what he did is is
amazing you know he made this movie for
you know 20 30 grand took it to Sundance
and sold it with the contract written
out in a napkin that's a true story
and the fact that he charged up credit
cards and sold his comic book collection
to get the money to make the film is is
amazing
you know it's it's like a real life
fairy tale
but I think Kevin on social media has
involved himself in conversations and
fights that uh I I just don't think he
needs to what does he need to prove
you know it's like he's stalking his own
fans he doesn't need to do that
so I so I was kind of reluctant to see
clerks three I wanted to see it it's the
third in a series of films uh that I've
enjoyed with characters that I've
enjoyed
and I saw clerks three and he got me
he got me I mean there's things that are
kind of cheesy about it I didn't love I
think at some point Kevin might want to
outgrow the
potty humor but
this movie Clerks 3 is a love letter to
Indie Cinema
it's
um sort of his version of Cinema
Paradiso in a sense and it's the best
performances ever out of Brian
O'Halloran and Jeff Anderson the two
actors that play uh Dante and Randall
at uh the Kwik-E-Mart you know like
they're the they're the clerks and
you'll
it's the best acting they've ever done
in their careers and uh he got me
Kevin Smith got me I'm sorry to admit
but it's sad because I think that there
is a huge audience of people who used to
be fans of Kevin Smith that
um have grown to they've they've sort of
moved away from his work because of how
he's presented himself on social media
I try to overlook those things and you
know
and I'm I'm I'm a little disappointed
that I think people are going to miss
out on clerks three
because of their feelings about the
artist it's tough to do sometimes
you know
it's really tough to do sometimes to
separate uh the real life person from
the work
but if you can look past it for you know
indiscretions on social media
uh you could you could benefit from that
kind of thinking
In fairness to talent to actors and
filmmakers screenwriters fans are just
as guilty of bullying so how do fans
bully artists
well I think I think
I think this gets down to the the fact
that there are just so few Stars these
days and I think a star is someone who's
on a pedestal
but now we have access to everybody
because everyone for the most part
are someone everyone's on social media
stars are accessible
I mean I can talk to Chris Pratt if I
want to
um I can talk to other
actors who are on social media
and I think this is diminished
diminished
actors it's it's the there's really very
few people I would I would classify as a
star
I would say Brad Pitt Tom Cruise
maybe Tom Hanks
but they're just very few real stars
today because they become so accessible
and even their
you know I tend to be someone that just
uh avoids gossip
and you know for years I didn't even
know that Nicole Kidman was married to
Tom Cruise I learned that later
um I feel like if it doesn't apply to a
movie I'm gonna see I don't really care
about a celebrity's personal life and I
think ignoring it will make you enjoy a
movie much more
but
but it's disheartening
that this tool
we're still learning how to use this
tool and misuse this tool
you know for a long time we didn't have
seat belts and cars and for a long time
doctors recommended smoking for your
health
my doctor recommends this cigarette oh
there's print ads you can find them
I think we're going to find out
I think we're going to find out that
social media is worse for us
than smoking
and in some cases you know it's like
holding a loaded weapon you could ruin
your career in a tweet
so it's unfortunate we're living in this
time
we're social media and so-called
influencers dominate so much
I just hope that we learn to use this
tool in a better way because it it's
really infected everything it's it's
affected entertainment
I mean the fact that studio marketing
departments care
what a small percentage of people
a Twitter mob thinks about a movie and
will thus make changes in a movie think
about that they're making changes in a
movie because a small percentage of
people on social media
care about this thing
when you could just as well say
here's the work who cares
don't go see it if you think it's
something you wouldn't like
um so
I think being beholden to the Twitter
mob is just the worst thing uh someone
who's creative can do
so do you think someone would see more
star-like if they're not accessible
because then there's like this mystery
yeah I think we've lost the mystery of
what a star is or a celebrity you know
we know too much about them including
who they voted for in the last election
which again just you know again just
sort of turns up the heat on the
rhetoric it's it's really disheartening
to see
so if Marilyn Monroe or Rita Hayworth
had been on Twitter
and we were able to see them too just
walking to get coffee or I mean is there
something about the fact that we don't
really know those Stars personal lives
that well we found it in tell all books
and things later on we got to know who's
who's with who whom
right I I just think uh it's it's I
think I think it's social media has
ruined a lot and in particular it's it's
you know destroyed the mystery of
celebrities and stars
and it's it's also now that it's like
you know it does affect the the content
that's made it's effect affected movies
and TV shows in ways that I don't think
are positive because you're listening to
a small percentage of the audience that
may or may not be a paying member of the
audience
what's the uh what is okay
all right here so I don't know I don't
know what I'm doing am I on a kids show
what is this the elephant in the room
what's the elephant in the room well
that's what we're wondering if you have
any take on
well I think the elephant in the room is
Hollywood is making movies for the mob
on social media and not for General
audiences when you look at the successes
that have uh been the biggest films of
the year they've all been very
mainstream movies top gun Maverick being
among them right and I think that
there's a whole section of the audience
that has felt alienated by the infusion
of too much agenda
and really you know I go to the movies
to escape
I go to the movies to get involved in
someone's story and that story and that
person whose story that I'm experiencing
through their eyes may not even look
like me may not be the same gender as I
am may not be the same ethnicity I don't
care I want to be involved in a human
story that I can relate to and by relate
to I don't mean I need to see someone
who looks exactly like myself I think
that what needs to happen is is that the
the films that Hollywood makes should
really be reflective of the actual
audience
that goes to the movies we have seen
this year as we've
you know gotten past the before times so
to speak
the the lowest box office while we've
had box office hits
we have had far less tickets sold
in the United States
I mean most recently by the end of the
summer and going into the fall some of
the worst weekends we've ever seen now
there'll always be a number one movie at
the box office but when compared to
previous years
Hollywood has certainly not recovered I
think part of that is that the habit of
going to the movies has been lost
I think that these specialness of big
tentpole Hollywood movies has been
diminished by the sh by the the
shortened window you know hey it's in
the theaters uh I'll wait I'll wait and
I'll see it later on my 4K 75 inch TV
what is going to get audiences back to
the box office and it's telling stories
that are more Universal
and that means getting away from
lecturing and getting away from Identity
politics and really stop infusing agenda
into what should be Universal
storytelling
it it's unfortunate because it used to
be a thing
where we'd all go to the movies and we'd
be talking about it the next week
right we would have discussions I liked
it I didn't like it my opinion about
that film is different than yours that's
fine I love love to disagree with people
about film my favorite conversations
I've ever had people I disagreed with
vehemently I love it it's the
conversation is the point it's not it's
not I'm not trying to be right okay
because we all have different
experiences we experience you know films
differently
so I'm still sitting here with this
elephant it's gonna
but I think really Hollywood needs to
get back to who is the core audience
how can we appeal to the most people but
in a way that doesn't seem pandering
and can there even be an American
identity I think this is kind of the
problem right now like we don't we we
disagree on so many so many issues
that I I think that's that's a difficult
task
so
um boy the challenges are out there for
Hollywood but uh just just get back to
the core entertaining people
and is the mob quote-unquote mob on
social media the new Focus Group
it's unfortunate that the mob on social
media is the focus group that's being
listened to I mean
focus groups can be useful right hey the
movie is 15 minutes too long we're
looking where where can we find 15
minutes to cut out
you know
um I I think that the mob on social
media is very vocal but they're not your
core customer and Studios need to stop
listening to the Mob
that's that's the elephant in the room
stop listening to the Mob listen to the
elephant in the room
and we're not talking Good Fellas here
no yeah exactly stop listening to Social
Media mobs that go after people these
are people that are bored and generally
sad because they've got the time to
express uh whatever their horrific an
annoying opinion is
get away from it stay true make make a
and make a film that
that is going to move people
I really do think we're going to look
back on this era of filmmaking and think
how did so many bad movies get made
and I hope that I'm there to be able to
look back and go
why did they make that Pinocchio movie
with Tom Hanks and then someone's going
to say wait a sec they made a Pinocchio
live action movie with Tom Hanks oh my
God I saw it you're not going to believe
it it actually exists
I'm going to name 12 Movies 12 woke
movies okay quote unquote and I'd love
to hear your reaction sure so first one
Thelma and Louise Thelma and Louise
could be considered woke
having said that I I don't consider that
movie uh in in the sense of how we see
woke today because that I don't feel
it's it's it doesn't lecture
I don't feel like I'm being lectured to
in that film but yeah that that has I
would say that it definitely has
Progressive messages but I wouldn't even
really necessarily put that in a woke
category
for me personally I think there's a
different way that messages have been
infused into Hollywood
in the past and it's very different now
where the messaging is right on the nose
and you're being told you're a bad
person if you don't actually like the
movie like if you don't like this if you
don't like this movie you're racist or
if you don't like this movie you're a
sexist or how could you not like this
movie because this person made it
um I kind of call BS on that
so and I don't necessarily consider it's
certainly a feminist film
for sure
you know
I don't have a problem with it do the
right thing get out
Fruitvale Station
Mad Max Fury Road Straight Out of
Compton All About Eve Mean Girls
Philadelphia Remember the Titans glory
and hidden figures
I don't know that I would call those all
woke films there's certainly movies that
I'll have messages right and and look
Hollywood films have always been filled
with messages I think what's new today
is that the messaging is infused in a
more overt way it used to be underneath
the surface the messages used to be the
subtext of the film
you know for example uh you know
just like Dances with Wolves right has a
lot of messages in it but it's but it's
it's
just right there I think that a lot of
films that are coming out now and the
reason people are reacting so poorly is
that audiences are being judged based on
if they like a movie or not
you're you're free to not like film and
Louise you're free to not like do the
right thing you're free to not like
those films that's perfectly fine
but it doesn't make but what I think is
interesting is they're trying to make
people out to be bad
for having a different opinion about a
movie
I've never seen this in my life
and I think that's that's kind of
I think that's what's turned a lot of
people off to a movie they may actually
enjoy but refuse to see
um there's a recent example of that the
movie The Woman King
which I think the woman King was
completely misrepresented in its
marketing it was marketed to be one
thing and then the movie is is something
something else there's much more to the
film
and
I've never seen this happen
um in a time that I've been around where
an audience is being accused of being
sexist or racist for not liking a film
or a particular filmmaker you're free to
not like those things
and the fact that people feel like they
have to go along with sort of the the
the what they think is the majority of
people in their peer group
well everyone thinks this so I'm gonna
I'm gonna also think that
and I I just find that kind of
weak-minded I always like people who
have uh different opinions
about about films
but I it's unbelievable to me that that
people
's opinion can can vilify them or make
people look differently how could you
not like this how could you not not like
this this particular film or filmmaker
never seen that ever before and I and I
find it kind of shocking
what I think is most disheartening is
when you see like a studio kind of use
it almost like a marketing strategy
you know this was this was done with
Amazon and the rings of power they tried
to accuse audiences of being racist for
not liking
the diverse cast
and there's quite a crossover audience
between fans of
Lord of the Rings and
Game of Thrones
and so HBO comes out with House of the
Dragon well that's also a diverse cast
and people love that show
so what is it
the same fans who were accused of being
racist for not liking the character of
Riva in the Obi-Wan Kenobi series
were also the same fans
who begged to please please
put Lando Calrissian in a Star Wars
movie
same fans
please please can you put Mace Windu
played by Samuel L Jackson please put
him in the Kenobi series
you can't accuse these fans of of of
those kinds of things I think it's it's
really disingenuous on the Studio's
parts and I think what they're doing is
is that they're sort of shielding
themselves from criticism
by making certain creative choices
and the fans can can like it or not like
it whatever
but I don't think they're they're racist
for not liking a particular film or
character you know some characters
resonate Lando Calrissian is a badass
love him
people love the character of Mace Windu
and what's weird is
um
so many so many today think like well
this is this is the first time we've
ever had a character
of color in in a film when you look back
in particular genre Science Fiction and
Fantasy has had diverse casts from the
beginning you know back in the 70s
so this is this is not new what's new is
using it as a piece of marketing and
weaponizing IT against audiences to me
it's always a losing strategy
it's always a losing strategy to do that
let the work speak for itself if people
don't like it don't vilify your audience
how often do you watch a movie or TV
show that you hate
oh I try to avoid watching movies or TV
shows that I hate
right now I think the one that I'm
watching that I vehemently dislike
is the Lord of the Rings the rings of
power
I I mean it's um but even but even then
I don't really hate the show I'm
I just don't care
but I feel
I I feel it's important that in order to
have an opinion about something
need to have seen it there's there there
is quite a contingent of people who have
lots of thoughts and opinions about
things that they know nothing about
and I believe it was Harlan Ellison who
taught me that
um the common phrase that you've heard
everyone has the right to their opinion
is incorrect
you only have a right to your informed
opinion
so generally
I like to wait to see
a TV show or a movie
before I form an opinion about it
there have been plenty of cases where
trailers especially these days the
trailers and marketing are deceptive
they represent completely differently
what a show is going to be and I think a
lot of that is pandering to to
journalists
to try to get them to think a certain
way about something but
I I don't know I think when it comes to
hate watching anything for me that
normally comes
comes along the lines of like reality
television
which reality television is like
is like it's like potato chips not good
for you they're not good for you but I'm
like that was the worst thing ever I
can't stand it this character I can't
believe that she's with him and he's
with her why did they break up and get
back together and I'm going to open up
another bag of chips so I tend to not
hate watch movies but I will 100 hate
watch reality television which is its
own form of Storytelling
and just to kind of give a little
background of where that came from
um
the the sort of competitive reality TV
shows like Survivor and whatnot
can be traced back to a documentary
called hands on a hard body
which is a movie that I believe played
Sundance and it's about a Texas truck
dealership car dealership that every
year they'd have a little promotion on
the radio where they would give away a
truck for free
all you had to do and they would select
people from the radio listening audience
and they would be selected as
contestants where they all they had to
do was put their hands on a truck and
the last person who still has their
hands on the truck gets to keep the
truck
this is a documentary film that I
strongly recommend that you seek out but
it's a documentary subject that you know
it's got a setup it's got a bunch of
variety of characters that we meet it's
got your main conflict you've got like
what the the goal of each character is
you know I want to get the truck because
my my old truck is not working I got you
know you meet all these different types
of people walks of life they do get
bathroom breaks right but you got to
keep your hands on that truck
and that
the success of that documentary I
believe led to these competitive reality
shows
I mean it's all storytelling right I
mean there are you'll see in the credits
small story producer right on a reality
show because they create these conflicts
but if I hate watch anything it's bad
reality television
and I hope you'll forgive me
you're forgiven I've done the same but
what is it what what do you get from it
like when you know it's like you know
you're supposed to stop doing something
but you can't what payoff do you get I
guess the payoff from you know hate
watching Bad reality TV for me is uh I
wanna I wanna see
I want to see a good outcome for the
people that I care about right so I want
to see the winner get the prize okay I
want to see the couple that should be
together remain together the couple that
should part let them go their separate
ways so I'd like to see some sort of
positive outcome it never really goes
that way but I do find reality
television
reality television is is useful it's
useful in terms of being able to
identify that this is storytelling like
other storytelling forms so you can't
completely dismiss it but I only ever
hate watch those shows
how much do you think hate watching has
increased in the last few years
well for me not that much I I feel like
my time is is is really valuable in
terms of like trying to juggle a lot of
projects you know I do a movie website I
have my own YouTube channel and I make
make movies on the side and um I don't
have a lot of time so if I'm going to
invest in something you know I'm hoping
for a good experience so I don't hate
watch stuff as much as I used to but if
I'm gonna hate watch anything it's
usually something where I want to
completely turn my brain off
which is always going to be something
from reality TV but it's interesting
that the roots of reality TV can be
traced to a little documentary from
decades ago and I think what was the
Seven Up series or something by the
British director
trying to think of what yeah seven up
that was where this British director
Revisited kids every seven years just to
see how they evolved and developed not
particularly a competition show per se
but an interesting kind of check-in uh
you know with like well how are they
surviving why
um yeah don't feel bad I got suckered
into Joe Millionaire I did also oh my
God you're one of the few people who've
seen that show
I you know I had tried to get my cable
shut off uh because I wanted to go cold
turkey I didn't want any more
distractions and then Joe Millionaire
came along and I but I didn't hate watch
it I was just intrigued by it
but but I can see that there is a trend
and we see it online and it's become a
new sport to hate watch
um and so I just was curious why
we've tipped the scales well yeah not
everything has to be you know when we
eat not everything has to be a salad or
stuff that's good for us you know you
can have a a cheeseburger from a fast
food restaurant and not everything in
our media consumption has to be a social
justice documentary that's very you're
being told is very important and you
feel really good for having sat there
and watched it
I'm informed I'm enlightened now
so um yeah you can you can watch bad
reality TV I won't judge okay thanks
well the road rules weren't wasn't bad
that was when you first kind of like set
it off as well but Road Rules and the
real world
MTV that was an interesting one so yeah
no all of that stuff
how do you deal with hate watching
because you have to watch so many things
but I don't like like I don't really
hate watching the sense of like I don't
know what I'm gonna see like I see a lot
of Indie movies that nobody sees see a
lot of independent films
um I may end up hating the movie at the
end but I'm always hopeful I'm always
optimistic
I'm always optimistic and especially
when it comes to Independent films you
know
um I tend to overlook flaws
because to me an independent film is
like a bird with a broken wing I want to
see it flourish I want to see it fly I
want to see it you know uh go on and
have its best possible life
but Independent films the deck is always
stacked against independent filmmakers
budget wise resources marketing
resources
it's it's the fact that you can make
anything watchable on an indie level is
remarkable to me so I always look for
that
so you're not setting out sorry to hate
it no no I'm not setting out to hate in
in especially an independent film but
there are independent films I've seen
that I really hated by the end oh man
I'm not going to name names but they
exist quite a few
Chris why do you love Halloween oh my
God first of all Halloween is the best
holiday of the year
it involves no relatives
it is the stress-free holiday
I generally get my decorations on in
September
you know Party City's always got the the
costumes out they're out in August
there's no competition Halloween is the
best holiday because
it's it's such low stress in addition it
is an excuse to revisit every horror
film that you love and it's also when
the studios say hey have we got some
horror films we should release them in
October but now it's like I feel like
that calendar has been pushed into
September for me it's more than a
month-long celebration so I love
Halloween
um
yeah I don't dress up as much as I used
to I used to dress up but no I the the
holiday is is great because it's sort of
top of mind for everybody of like oh
yeah that's I'm gonna go see the new
whatever horror film
but yeah absolutely my favorite personal
holiday what was your costume of choice
oh man
um let's see I once dressed as Luke
Skywalker from Return of the Jedi in
high school
that was in my senior year in my junior
year
I dressed as Alex from Clockwork Orange
I literally had the white jock strap on
the outside the Jack Boots the bowler
hat
the the single eyelash and eyeball on my
on on the you know my shirt collar my
anyways or on the on the anyways it was
a very accurate
costume for Clockwork or A Clockwork
Orange
and no one knew who I was not one single
person in my high school knew who I was
and there were a couple teachers that
looked at me and said
how do you even know that movie
so
yeah
um but yeah no and more recently I
dressed as like Logan from Logan's Run
but I was Logan after he went to the new
you I just think that like Halloween is
not just an opportunity to you know uh
enjoy parties it's stress-free because
it doesn't involve family or travel
family and travel can be stressful
During certain holidays and you know
it's it's just non-stop parties and then
it's also enjoying horror movies and
getting to dress up like an adult
without judgment
and and so what's not to love about
Halloween
even theme parks make it a month-long
celebration everything from Universal
Horror Nights uh not scary farm
Disneyland even does their their own
Halloween
events so
I love Halloween you're not ever gonna
convince me and plus I I you know it's
I'll always discover new horror films I
haven't seen during Halloween
what are your top five go-to horror
films oh wow well first off Night of the
Living Dead the Original
1968 George Romero is absolutely one of
my favorites
um frightened me beyond belief
that one uh John Carpenter's The Thing
horrific I saw that when I was a
teenager and it was the last time I ever
remember sleeping with the light on
because I was so terrified
uh the original Halloween the very first
Halloween with Jamie Lee Curtis
uh blew my mind
I would say alien
1979 Ridley Scott original alien is a
horror film that
um I mean yes people sort of put that in
the science fiction category but it uh
that's a horror film that holds up
to today
and uh
I got I got one more choice I got one
more
see now this is like a Sophie's choice
of Horror you've put me in this position
uh
I'm gonna say Poltergeist
because I love Lloyd Kaufman
it's weird it's more of a horror comedy
and uh it's it's about fast food
and then
um honorable mention to Evil Dead 2 and
Bruce Campbell in that movie
see I I got six out of it
which Halloween movies do you watch
every year Night of Living Dead I'll
watch at least once a year I used to own
so Night of the Living Dead I would
watch not just once a year I used to
when I was a kid I had a Super 8 sound
projector I had a full print of Night of
the Living Dead
okay and it was the way I find it found
out like because I'd only ever seen
Night of the Living Dead on some Chiller
theater or late night you know horror
host so I'd seen it then I didn't
realize the movie was cut when I finally
got the Super 8 version all the kids in
in the neighborhood where I grew up in
Royal Oak Michigan we'd put a sheet on
the side of the garage and we'd get
popcorn and I would project Night of the
Living Dead you know full unedited
there's like full frontal nudity in that
movie there's gory stuff with guts and
intestines I mean it's a graphic movie
that George Romero really made for the
drive-in but uh at the time when I was a
kid didn't realize probably probably an
R-rated movie
and only got to see it because I had a
Super 8 projector and with money I saved
for my paper route got the complete
feature
but yeah that's one that um I like to
watch every year is is Night of the
Living Dead it's just
it's just it's so inspiring because it's
such a simple story
it's low budget
and most of the action I mean everybody
says the zombies are the villains in
that movie I think the zombies are a
catalyst
for all the tensions between the people
that are in the bordered up house that's
where the real conflict lies and that's
I think the Brilliance of George Romero
was to focus on that aspect
so that's that's a Halloween movie I
watch every year of course you know
Halloween without watching Halloween
it's just it just doesn't feel like
Halloween the John Carpenter original
with uh Jamie Lee Curtis is just I mean
just the sound of that score right you
just hear that score and it's fantastic
so
yeah those are those are those are ones
that I revisit can you recommend any
independent films that are Halloween
based
indie horror films yeah the very first
Evil Dead which I think when you watch
that film what I love about watching
that movie is just what little resources
Sam Raimi had to make the first Evil
Dead film
you know he he used like stop-motion
animation a lot of other techniques one
of my favorite techniques that he used
and he used this not just for the first
evil dead but the second one as well
he called it a shaky cam
and it's sort of a
it's what he what he did was he would
take a camera he would mount it on a two
by four and run with it or ride a
bicycle
and it's sort of a the shaky cam is a
low budget version of a Steadicam
literally just took a camera put it in
the center of the board right so it's
weighted it's in the center you have
like a seesaw the center of the Seesaw
is the camera and when you run with it
it gives it a smooth look so Sam Remy
used that for at least the early Evil
Dead films not sure if he used it in
Evil Dead 3 but they would call it the
shaky camera and I just love that that
it's like well we've got no money we
can't afford to rent a steady cam
you know but we're gonna just create one
and they used a two by four
as a kid what was your favorite
Halloween candy that you would always go
back to that house every year uh well
it's going to be a tie for me it's
malted milk balls because I love the
taste of malted milk and raisin heads
raisinets because
you know it's kind of the healthy candy
I you know it's got chocolates
but then recently I just found out
there's tons of sugar in raisins
and I was very disappointed to learn
this but I'm still I'm a raisinet's
popcorn and soda guy at the movies
because of that
Chris you recently celebrated a birthday
congratulations thank you very much yeah
happy belated birthday we got you a
small gift or two and
because it's your birthday we're
wondering do you have a birthday wish a
birthday wish for Cinema
oh wow yeah first of all I I don't love
my birthday uh in the sense that I'm
terrible I love to give gifts don't get
me wrong I'm terrible at receiving them
so I'll do my best and thank you so much
uh but no I a birthday wish uh you know
I wish
truthfully if I have a serious birthday
wish I wish we could communicate
respectfully
between each other and by that I mean I
look at the internet or I'll look at the
comments section on a YouTube video and
I see people arguing and debating and
there is there are a lot of people that
are
um they're basically dug in on what
their view is they're trying to convince
everyone that theirs is the Right View
and they want to win
and I feel like that attitude
generally doesn't lead to the result
that you're looking for
I think if the result that you want is
to win someone's win the hearts and
minds of people it's never to go about
it in a way that's aggressively you're
wrong
and if I really had a wish I think that
we could solve many of the bigger
problems in our world if we learn to
communicate on the internet I don't know
that our brains were really wired to
communicate on these black mirrors that
we all have in our pockets
we're this is all just happening too
fast social media technology all the
different we've learned to solve all
sorts of problems
I can have cheeseburgers delivered to my
house using a phone
and I can I can get a ride to him to a
movie theater when my car is broken down
but we hardly are able to talk to each
other and I feel like if there's one
thing if this could be a true wish I
wish we could learn to communicate
between each other where we we respect
each other's views we we learn to also
um you know just
just this is your view we'll we'll kind
of respectfully disagree
and I don't see that happening hardly
anywhere
I only really see it happening in real
life
you know I'll see the sort of how how
depressing the internet is and and then
I go off and I go for a walk in my
neighborhood in Pasadena and people are
nice to each other all sorts of
different people and that would be my
wish I mean I I don't think you were
expecting a really serious answer to
that most people would say World Peace
um since that is impossible just I do
think that at some point we'll be able
to evolve and and to be able to just
talk to each other
we cannot agree on things and that's
okay
agree to disagree yeah and be okay with
that yeah we used to be able to do that
but suddenly agreeing to disagree uh
it's not enough
so I hope we get to that place because I
do think that that is the pathway
towards
solving
real problems
do you see any positive signs in the
movie industry that give you hope
the positive signs are I think when a
film that
um film is a hit that's unexpected
I think top gun Maverick being a hit
that
surprised people it's kind of almost
like it's like that movie was made in a
bubble in another period of time or when
I see like a small Indie movie like this
horror film Barbarian
that came out recently it's done very
well at the box office so uh I like that
those are those things kinds of things
are encouraging but I would like to see
more authenticity at at the movies I
think
um I think that you've seen the rise of
certain YouTubers and their popularity
of YouTube and
certain YouTubers is because I think
what people respond to is authenticity
you know
I feel like when you ask me questions
I feel obligated to tell you the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth I know I didn't swear in a Bible I
know we're not in court but you asked me
a question I'm going to give you my
honest answer you know for good or bad
you're gonna you're gonna hear it from
me and I think that this is the rise of
YouTube is a platform where it's not
just people talking
um in an authentic way I think the most
popular YouTubers the one thing they all
have in common is they're authentic
they're authentic to Their audience I
think audiences can see through
inauthenticity but I'd like to see that
in movies I like to see that also in
movies I'd like to see more stories
authentically told all right well this
is very cute I appreciate this oh my God
who doesn't love a delicious cupcake we
weren't sure I love cupcakes okay okay
oh this is great great great and then a
wrapped gift what is this no need to go
through this much trouble but this is
this is awesome
thank you totally unnecessary what is
this oh no look at that it's the classic
Star Wars figures you already have it no
I don't have these okay this is great
you know what I know exactly they're
going on the cupcakes okay they're
definitely gonna go on the cupcakes that
is awesome wow thank you so much oh
you're welcome
you know what you know what I have a new
hope for this industry
My Hope Is you will take all this
knowledge
and you will go off and you will create
your own thing whatever that is
create
do something creative every day one of
my favorite Oscar speeches ever was it
was when Steven Soderberg won the Oscar
for best director
and he dedicated his Oscar for the
people who do something creative every
day do something creative every day I
don't know what that is it could be
writing it could be making something
some art project could be making a movie
could be something small be creative and
uh really um to me creativity is and
being creative and the Act of Creation
is like therapy for the soul
so I'm just gonna put these Star Wars
figures on cupcakes and eat them